the Joe Rogan experience need it why did
you see what happened at this World
Series game the other night you see the
news
no they introduced Trump and the first
lady and they got booed do you know this
yeah it's going he's two different
versions the story I saw yeah when n was
saying that they were yelling out lock
her up but then I didn't hear that I
just other thing was saying they were
saying lock him up lock him up I think
it was lock him up as with everything
and then had it where they were saying
people were chanting lock her up I said
the other thing too is he was generally
the president throws out the first pitch
yeah and he didn't do that because he's
already thrown one out somewhere and
it's been it's did very good yeah
athletic [ __ ] you want to talk about
those we got some clips in the vault of
people that can't throw baseballs on the
furniture Apatow it's my favorite
[ __ ] clip Gary Dell'Abate him 50 cent
there's a few people never [ __ ] know
I can't right now I'm good
will you stomach yeah um I don't want to
[ __ ] I don't want to [ __ ] yeah it's
fine but I don't want to film that I
don't want to dance on the edge did you
see what I tweeted I tweeted this
morning uh Burr and CNN's I typed him
lock her up it's just his pop putting
back lock him up
hold on Burr and burr and and cry sure
have a podcast now called Bill and Bert
podcast and I made fun of him you should
pull up the image for it because they
[ __ ] they have a cigar and a glass of
whiskey and their icon but I go what is
up with this cigar dick
you guys got as your [ __ ] image look
at this thing look at that what's up
with that cigar [ __ ] that is not I go
you got to get someone to reanimate that
bro
that is a weird-looking cigar it looks
like a [ __ ] dick why is it all
rounded off at the tip it's not a set
the bill Bert podcast Oh whoever you're
hiring and all things comedy pay him
some real money they're mad at you
they're mad at you these guys are things
like dicks just [ __ ] wave so what did
it say did it say block
lock him up or lock her up his lock him
up Brady lock him up was another scene
yeah they booed the president has that
ever happened at a [ __ ] baseball game
no people are people are very riled up
man a laya
well here was the other thing that I saw
they had a connected thing are two
you know that I was reading with that
that said 51% of America is
pro-impeachment but I was like where
does that [ __ ] pole come from yeah
whose did they ask you know they didn't
ask me yeah so what the flu the [ __ ]
said all those poles here's the problem
with poles the only people that answer
poles are [ __ ]
right right right if they call you up
and go hey cheeto what do you what do
you think about this you're this one I
think don't call me yeah leave me alone
[ __ ] you who even candy can you see who
conducted that poll that that nonsense
of the impeachment part where you called
because that's very relevant opinions
about this impeachment if we go back to
Nix and really take pay attention makes
administration it's arguable that Trump
has been more egregious with his
breaking of the Constitution I'm so
exhausted I wish there was no issues huh
this is what I wish I wish there was no
one trying to steal there was no one
trying to cheat on their taxes kill
everybody was just doing their best and
helping each other out yeah it's a nice
small healthy vibrant communicative
community of people supporting each
other Fox News poll 51% of voters favor
impeachment and removing President Trump
from office that's not good that's a Fox
poll when Fox says that yeah that's [ __ ]
it's kind of luck in July was 42% but
I'm saying where from where though I'd
like need to know where the havre look
at that impeach but not removed in July
was 5% and now it's 4%
now most people favor him being removed
again again I don't know
[Applause]